نحن الان نتواجد امام حجز العسكري شماليه
القدس المحتله حيث خرج جنود الاحتلال
الدوليات العسكريه وذلك للقمع المتظاهرين
والفلسطينيين بقنابل الصوت وقنابل الغاز
وايضا بالرصاص المعدني المغلف في المطار
هذه التظاهره التي انطلقت في العشرات من
الفلسطينيين انطلقت من امام مخيم الامعري
للاجئين وسط المدينه في رام الله وتوجهت
الى الحاجز العسكريه وذلك للتمديد بجريمه
الاحتلال الاستمرار في الاستمراره باحتجاز
الشهداء الفلسطينيين في ثلاجات الموتى
وايضا فيما يعرف مقابل الارقام تقدمت هذه
المسيره التي انطلقت من داخل مدينه رام
الله والده الاسير ناصر ابو حميد وايضا
عائلات الشهداء وايضا هناك ممثلون عن
المؤسسات الحقوقيه والقانونيه الذين اكدوا
من خلال هذه المسيره التي رفع خلال نعش
فارغ للتنديد بهذه الجريمه وهذه السياسه
التي يقولون انها هي سياسه غير اخلاقيه
وايضا تخالف القانون الدولي باحتجاز
فيتامين الشهداء في سلطات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي المؤسسات الحقوقيه تحدثت عن ان
وسبعه فلسطينيه او جسمانا ما زالوا يا يا
محتجازينا لدى سلطات الاحتلال في ثلاجات
الموت منذ عام 2015 وايضا هناك اكثر من
250 جثمانه اخرين مدفنون فيما يعرف بمقابر
الارقام في داخل اسرائيل سمير ابو شمالي
الجزيره من حاجز قلنديا العسكريه الشماليه
القدس المحتله